KELSEY DOMME: The
Cloud Sales Role
has been such an
amazing journey.
It's just really exciting
what we get to do every day.
We talk with all different
kinds of customers.
JAMIE SHARP: The role gives
you quite a lot of freedom.
The ultimate goal
isn't just revenue,
but it's actually
customer success.
KELSEY DOMME: We're outreaching.
You're trying to
break new accounts.
But you're also dealing with
accounts that are already
using Google Cloud
Platform and G Suite
and asking them, hey,
how's it going, providing
that white glove
treatment to really
make sure they have the
best experience with Google.
JAMIE SHARP: My favorite
example of that is Pokemon Go.
They were able to go
from zero at launch
to being bigger than Twitter
in five days, entirely
on Google Cloud.
Someone described it to me--
our role in sales--
as being like selling
guitars to rock stars.
You can really feel like you're
a part of something special.
KELSEY DOMME: We're a provider
that's for the people.
We're working directly
with our customers
that are using and getting the
most out of what we provide.
KETAN PATEL: I think
the folks we're
looking for have to be
passionate, driven, smart.
We're looking for people
that are connected,
that want to work
as a team, right?
This is a team play.
JAMIE SHARP: It's
a little cheesy,
but the best part of the role
is unquestionably the team.
Being able to work so closely
with account executives who
are the best of the
best in enterprise sales
has been a wonderful
learning opportunity.
And being able to have front-row
seats to all the product
development and innovation
that's going on in Google Cloud
is amazing.
KETAN PATEL: I think
the future is infinite.
When you think about how
connected this world is
becoming, you talk
about by adding devices
into that as well.
They'll be classification
around the Internet of Things.
The potential is infinite.
And this is a platform
that we call Cloud actually
provides the underpinning,
or the foundation,
on how these companies
will actually
deliver those services.
KELSEY DOMME: Were just now
offering it to the public.
It's the same infrastructure
we've been using internally
since the beginning of Google.
But customers are
excited about it.
They're excited
about the products
we're talking to them
about, the solutions we're
talking to them about.
KETAN PATEL: If you want
to fundamentally transform
and change what we're
doing and how technology's
consumed in today's marketplace,
this is a place to be.